p42 here the year is 1902 12 young men
at the peak of their physical fitness
and the peak of their careers are sat
around the table dressed in their finest
evening wear silver cutlery and crisp
white linen adorn the table they are
served only the highest quality food
cooks with the expertise of a top chef
and a top toxicologist because every
mouthful of this delicious food has been
laced with poison from formaldehyde and
a mashed-potato to borax in the lungs
shank every tasty meal is laden with
chemicals intended to kill humans but
these men were very aware what they were
eating and it's a willingly for they
were the poison squad the willing
participants of this macabre squad were
mostly medical students or employees of
the Bureau of chemistry for five years
the men sat down to a nightly meal
prepared by a government-run kitchen
they will be fed a range of toxic and
poisonous substances mixed up and hidden
within their meals each member of the
squad was monitored meticulously at all
times to observe the effects if a member
started to get seriously ill from a
poison their dose would be reduced the
poison squad was a daring new experiment
by chemists dr. Harvey Wylie its goal
was to identify harmful substances that
were making their way into our food so
that food labeling could be improved you
see up to this experiment manufacturers
would took any old substances into food
products to achieve the desired effects
such as strychnine and bitter beer and
arsenic in children's sweet something
had to be done and this daring
experiment by the large part in the
creation of the Food and Drug
Administration the yearly experiment and
that the Pure Food and Drug Act of 1906
was passed in the u.s. sadly one member
of the poison squad died due to his
organs eventually shut him down from
Ollie ingested poison
thankfully we've come a long way from
having to eat poison to test our food
products even though practically
everything we eat today is pretty much
safe we all know at least one
picky eater that friend who will eat
nothing but fried chicken and then of
course there's the other guy you know
who will eat absolutely anything from
olives to deep fried insects
maybe the picky eater is you but what
separates these two people we're all
born with the same equipment for tasting
food so why do certain foods provoke
reactions of disgust even hate and some
people there is one particular animal
that knows all too well about picky
eating the rat rats are one of nature's
pickiest animals for one good reason
they don't possess the ability to vomit
if we're at ingest something toxic and
gets food poisoning it has no mechanism
to get rid of the spoiled food from its
body which can often be fatal
rats have therefore evolved to be
extremely suspicious of new foods and
will do something called sampling when
they come across new food rats will
taste a tiny bit of the food to see if
it makes them sick if it doesn't then
they will return later and gobble a
whole lot so fortunately we humans have
various mechanisms to protect ourselves
against food poisoning when we can often
recover from a dodgy meal without
medical assistance but just like the
ramps are picking up about certain foods
comes from our evolutionary past
scientists have studied why some people
are adverse to some foods and they
suspect it has to do with our time spent
as hunter-gatherers long before and even
for many hundreds of thousands of years
after our hominid ancestors invented the
sphere and overhunting tools we had to
forage to survive without farming and
because hunting meat was unpredictable
our ancestors had to live off foraged
nuts seeds berries and vegetation to
survive
but many berries nuts and plants contain
deadly poisons that would incapacitate
or kill humans if ingested so evolution
devised a clever way for our ancestors
to identify which foods might be toxic
we developed taste balls thousands of
tiny receptors on our tongue that detect
five elements of taste sour salty sweet
umami and most importantly bitter the
toxic substances and poisons found in
certain wild berries nuts and plants
contain lots of bitter tasting compounds
so with our ancestors thought something
in their mouth which tasted bitter there
was a good chance it could have been
poisonous this was an intelligent and
highly effective system but of course
today we no longer need to detect
poisons in our food today food
production is highly regulated in all
developed countries we can simply read
the packaging to find out exactly what's
in our food but a distaste for bitter
food - still embedded deep within our
DNA we generally find bitterness
unpleasant but of course this is not a
universal rule for everyone some people
hate the bitter dated broccoli but many
of us love it researchers have found it
all has to do with our DNA when it comes
to bitterness there are two types of
genes
paster gene and non tasters the taster
gene has been passed down from our
hominid ancestors whereas those with the
non taster gene which is a relatively
recent mutation within the gene pool
don't taste the bitterness in vegetables
such as broccoli and sprouts but of
course everybody gets two of these genes
one from each parent if you happen to
get to non-tested genes then
congratulations you are super lucky
because you can't taste the
in vegetables and of a bitter foods but
it on the other hand you get to taster
jeans from your parents then you're most
likely a very picky eater especially
when it comes to your green because not
only can you taste bitterness but you're
extremely sensitive to it to new foods
such as broccoli will taste almost
inevitably bitter your body will be
repulsed the second it touches your
tongue so if you do know someone who is
picky about their veg maybe you should
put them a little flat because it's not
actually their fault it's in their DNA
you may be wondering what happens if you
get one gene from each parent a non
taster and the taste regime researchers
have found that such people may not like
the taste of bitter food when they're
younger sports crew repeatedly train
such food they can actually learn to
like them as they grow older and
potentially even if ppreciate bitter
flavor this is why certain foods that
you absolutely hate it when you were
younger are no longer a problem for you
when you hit your 20s or 30s so that
covers the vast majority of people's
food choices but what's about the
extremely picky eaters those individuals
that categorically will not eat anything
was an extremely limited selection of
food you know that person who will only
eat cereal and nothing else and then
there's that other person who won't eat
anything that casts a shadow
oh wait that's meals in such individuals
the cause is more than just genetics and
we start to enter the realm of
psychology doctors believe they may have
diagnosed such extreme for selita's and
it turns out that they have a genuine
eating disorder it's called food
neophobia we all experience neophobia to
some extent it's simply the fear or
apprehension or trying something new or
unfamiliar what trulia phobics take that
layer to a whole of a level where even
the force of eating
anything except what they used to make
them feel nauseous it's believed that
neophobia has its roots in genetics and
having certain genes can increase a
person's near phobic tendencies however
to reach a high level of neophobia where
a person will outright refuse to eat
anything new even something that many
other people would find quite desirable
such as pizza there needs to be an added
psychosocial factor on top of that
genetics when growing up if children
don't experience their parents eating a
wide variety of foods or never trying
new foods they are much more likely to
develop neophobia
and of course parents who are rather on
adventurous with their culinary cuisine
there are far more likely to give their
children uninspired and very similar
food night after night which only makes
the likelihood of the child developing
neophobia far far worse the biggest
problem with neophobia is that once it
sets its claws into a child it's
extremely hard to greatest hope and in
the vast majority of cases it continues
well into adults so how do we prevent
neophobia from developing in the first
place well the answer lies to the east
in a magical unbel our place called
japan i've taught previously about how
japan is the healthiest country in the
world with the highest life expectancy
it's one being for that how we are
taught to eat as a child stays with us
our whole lives and hugely affects our
eating habits as an adult for better or
for worse Japanese culture has taken
this to the extreme and Japanese
children eat of far more varies and
healthier diet than kids in every other
country which could explain why they
have such long life expectancies
Japanese children have the lowest
childhood obesity rates in the developed
world and it's easy to see why snacking
between meals is unheard of and Japanese
kids are strongly encouraged to never
snap at least not until after they beat
Japanese children also eat exactly what
their parents eat which gets them you
through a wide variety of foods and
cuisines from a very early age
there's no microwave chicken nuggets for
the kids and then a completely different
meal for the parents as is common in
many Western homes but this approach to
food doesn't stop outside of the home
Japanese school dinners are often
praised as being the highest quality and
healthiest of any country every meal is
cooked from scratch every morning in the
school kitchen quality ingredients are
sourced from local farms a typical
Japanese school dinner consists of a few
different elements that vary each day
but it usually includes tofu and
vegetables in miso soup rice with
seaweed and fish or meat would even more
vegetables if a kid doesn't like that
meal then talk because there is only
ever one option each day there is no
choice at Meal Time for Japanese school
tools whatever is cooked that day is
what they will eat because let's face it
there's absolutely no point in offering
a healthy option if ninety-nine percent
of the children I'll still go to opt for
pita chips but having no other choice
works so well in Japan because there are
practically no picky eaters in their
society eating disorders such as
neophobia
are pretty much non-existent in Japan
and maybe that's due to their food
culture within the home and it's school
so when it comes to eating habits maybe
we should all try to be a little more
Japanese would that be sort of rustic I
mean they have ramen everybody likes
ramen thanks for watching I'm really
excited to present this limited edition
42 t-shirt I've created this exclusively
for fans but it will only be available
for the next two weeks there's a link in
the video description to get yours but
remember this is a limited time flash
sale so when it's gone it's gone I'd
love to get your feedback on this as
well because it'd be great to create
more products
found in the future
[Music]